hello my name is Mary similar kerr i'm
pleased to come and speak with you today
about chronic illness and how to
overcome it in my life I've experienced
both the good and the bad of chronic
illness and I have severe lung disease
now pulmonary fibrosis but all of my
life I was faced with the challenge of
very severe asthma from childhood on and
it just my lungs have just gotten
progressively worse over time in 2007 I
was diagnosed with pulmonary fibrosis
and after exhausting all the medications
and oxygen and everything I could with
my normal phone the pulmonologist I went
for an evaluation at johns hopkins
university medical center and that's
where i was diagnosed and at that time i
was told that the average pulmonary
fiber on occasion lives five to seven
years post diagnosis and i'm now ten
years into that diagnosis oh you can see
that I've made more progress than my
physicians expected me to but whenever I
get really bad news I am a realist and
I'm an optimist at the same time in that
I don't take bad news lightly however I
also don't take it in a fatalistic way I
want to overcome it and so I'm always
looking for that new challenge in my
personal life at the same time which is
like sort of the unfair you know when it
rains it pours story Isaac began to
experience what I like to call my own
personal reign of terror and I lost the
people eight people closest to me in my
life in an eight-year period of time
while at the same time the lung disease
was getting worse and so it was just a
double whammy and I got so depressed at
one point because of complicated grief
that I came to the point of thinking
about suicide and actually apparently
having a psychotic break with reality my
neighbors heard me screaming one night
and they called the ambulance and that's
how I woke up in a psych ward in a
straitjacket strapped to a bed
and when I woke up in this all-white
room I had absolutely no idea where I
was and I had been there for nine days
as I later found out this was really an
eye-opener for me I for the eighth for
the probably five years prior to that I
knew that I was seriously ill with not
only my lung disease but also in my
psyche I was seeing on maybe on monday
wednesday and friday i'd see my
psychiatrist and on tuesdays and
thursdays and sometimes saturday in the
ER as the pulmonologist that's too many
doctors in one's life and so i had to
find ways to cope with it and I really I
really came to that finding it out in a
really stark way in the site in the
hospital in the psychiatric treatment I
was fortunate enough to have a wonderful
psychiatrist and he came up with two
very creative ways for me to overcome my
what I we now know is an existential
vacuum I had no idea what I was going to
do with myself how was going to get
better where I was going to live but I
knew that I couldn't keep staying in my
home where there was no but nothing but
pictures of dead people on my walls and
nothing but oxygen tanks and medical
equipment set up I had to plan a new
life when i said earlier that i had both
the good experience with the good and
the bad about chronic illness the good
news about this having chronic illness
and being forced to stop and what you're
doing get off that fast train of i have
to make more money you have to build a
bigger business i have to do this i have
to do that and coming and being stopped
in your dead dead in your tracks and
then really understanding at the pit of
your soul what you need to do and what's
really important in life and it's
certainly not making money in building
bigger businesses it's being healthy
finding new people to love after you've
after loss and so he came up with two
creative ways for me to plan a new life
for myself he said why don't you think
since you're good at business why don't
you create a business plan for Mary to
point o make it like a real company with
those great board of directors and
that's and I said well no that's
something I can really wrap my head
around because I love to
to create and develop incubate
businesses and the second thing he said
is I'd like for you to read this book
man's search for meaning and I laughed I
miss laughed in his face because I said
I know all about Franco I read his book
in college I met him I know all about
his work and he said well humor me read
it again because it never hurts to read
it again and once i had done both of
those things I really understood
suffering at its core and and I
understood dr. Frankel's work in a way
that I hope most people don't have to
find out firsthand having experienced
the trauma that I experience and having
lived it and living with experience of
the trauma of my own chronic illness I
was forced to understand dr. Frankel's
work at a deeper level so that I could
uncover new meaning in my own life and
he was very very smart I mean obviously
one of the great geniuses of the world
and he taught us three ways that we can
create uncover meaning in our lives
first we can find a way to create
something will I do that with businesses
producing movies producing digital
content I always and create I'm always
creative the second way we can find that
is to experience someone to find a
person to love I've done that I knew
again and the third way we can do it is
to change our attitude towards suffering
or toward any circumstance and and you
don't have to suffer to find meaning but
there is meaning and suffering and that
I learned first hand and so I utilized
wrinkles work in a in both the a
thoughtful way and a meaningful way to
uncover meaning and and I learned that I
could cope and I could get up every
single day and I still have to do that I
have to get up every single day and
realize that I'm not the person I was at
age 35 or 40 who wasn't sick and I have
to
realign and adjust my new reality every
single day okay today you're breathing
pretty good but you're still going to
have to spend two hours Mary taking
medication before you can start your
work day so I get up a little bit
earlier and I plan for whatever the
circumstance is going to be for example
if I know that I'm going out to dinner
that night I don't eat the whole day
because when they eat it lowers it makes
my diaphragm go up and because it
squeezes up the belly and then it it
shortens my vital capacity I don't have
as much air and I can't breathe so I
waited till the latest possible moment
in the day to even eat a meal and those
kind of things you do I had to bring my
office home because it was too much it
drained too much of my energy to go to
the office every day so I brought my
office home and so I work from home now
and I created I found created a new
business film company so I can be a
producer and work from my own computer
in my house so for the most part so what
I would advise anyone who's overcoming
chronic illness and facing a possible
terminal illness is adjust your attitude
in every moment moment by moment minute
by minute day by day year by year and
adjust to that new reality and realize
that you will find is dr. Frankel taught
us meaningful moments every step of the
way I always tell students when I'm
talking about this that they can also
adapt my personal mantra and that is if
you live your life from the inside out
and not from the outside in most of your
day is going to be wonderful anyway
thank you for listening